president Trump plays chicken with Nancy
Pelosi and Chuck Schumer president Trump
heads to the border and he considers
declaring a national emergency we'll
talk about all of it I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show so perhaps
you're watching you're wondering what is
that magnificent mane let me just tell
me yesterday on this very show we talked
a little bit about the fact that back in
the day I had a I had gone a few days
without shaving before my show someone
tweeted out that picture I took a poll
yesterday asking how many people wanted
to see bearded Shapiro versus no beard
versus paper bag over head well
fortunately beard came out first and so
overnight because I have to shave like
five times a day overnight
I just didn't shave then the next
morning this magnificent maid was
present here it was it was just great
we're gonna get to all the actual news
in just one second first I need to tell
you about market volatility a great
article just came out in the LA Times
about market volatility driving
investors back to traditional havens
okay a golden bonds they quote an
economist out of Capital Economics in
London quote safe havens should continue
to outperform this year as a slowdown in
the US prompts the Fed to end its
tightening cycle in the middle of the
year and China's economy continues to
lose momentum so if you haven't reviewed
your retirement accounts lately it's
time to take a look at some alternatives
what's your plan can you afford another
hits your retirement like the last
downturn when the S&P dropped 50% hedge
against inflation and hedge against
uncertainty and instability with some
precious metals I'm diversified you
should be to gold as a safe haven
against uncertainty the company I trust
with precious metal purchases as you
know Birch gold group and right now
thanks to a little-known IRS tax law you
can even move your eyewear IRA or
eligible 401k into an IRA backed by
physical gold and silver if that's
something you choose to do look back
historically when the bottom falls out
of everything else gold tends to tape
safeguard savings Birch gold group has
thousands of satisfied customers
countless five-star reviews an A+ rating
with the Better Business Bureau contact
Birch gold group get a free information
kit on physical precious metals see if
diversifying into gold and silver makes
sense for you it's comprehensive 16-page
kit it shows you how gold and silver can
help you so go check it out right now
birchgold.com slash man ask all your
questions and when you're ready to
invest talk to my friends at Birch gold
birchgold.com slash burn will do a lot
to get to today the President of the
United States traveling down to the
southern border to discuss I guess the
issue of
necessity for a border wall it's more of
a photo-op than anything else as he
continues to consider the possibility of
doing some sort of national emergency
declaration yesterday yesterday I have
to say yesterday
the the President of the United States
met with Nancy Pelosi and Chuck Schumer
both of whom were less than pleased with
the held the meeting what here are their
reactions to the meeting federal workers
will not be receiving their paychecks
and what that means in their lives is
tragic in terms of their credit rating
paying their mortgage paying their rent
paying their car payment paying their
children's tuition and the rest the
president seems to be insensitive to
that he thinks maybe they could just ask
their father for more money but they
can't the president just got up and
walked down
he asked Speaker Pelosi will you agree
to my wall she said no and he just got
up and said then we have nothing to
discuss and he just walked out again we
saw a temper tantrum because he couldn't
get his way and he just walked out of
the meeting
well Democrats were super pissed about
this president Trump met with both
Pelosi and Schumer and apparently
according to President Trump it went
something like what Pelosi and Schumer
said although without the temper tantrum
here is what President Trump tweeted out
yesterday he tweeted out just left a
meeting with Chuck and Nancy a total
waste of time I asked what is going to
happen in 30 days if that quickly opened
things up are you going to approve
border security which includes a wall or
steel barrier and as he said no I said
bye-bye
nothing else works and it turns out he
actually did say bye-bye no joke he
actually turned to them and said bye and
then he just left this was after
apparently he'd handed out candy
according to the vice president of the
United States Mike Pence president Trump
wasn't upset during the meeting he just
was not surprised that Democrats were
not willing to negotiate and so he
opened the meeting by handing out candy
and then when you didn't get what he
wanted he walked out walked into the
room passed out candy
what's wrong
but I don't I don't recall him ever
raising his voice or slamming his hand
but this is a president who feels very
strongly about his commitment to see to
the security of the American people okay
so you know this whole thing is bound
for ruin there there is no deal that is
on the table and the only deals that are
being considered as we'll discuss in a
little while are not going to be great
for the sort of border hawk side of the
Republican caucus I will say that the
idea of President Trump offering Nancy
Pelosi of Snickers him just going up to
her and saying you not you and you're
hungry
and then just handing her a Snickers bar
then she takes a bite and she turns into
Ben Roethlisberger or something that
would have been very amusing or he could
have gone with the Donald Jr routine and
he could have actually handed Nancy
Pelosi a bowl of skittles and then told
her that one of them was poisoned and
said well one of these is put and she
would say well I don't want to eat any
of these like that's just like illegal
immigration you don't know which one is
poisoned so you know solid stuff
happening in the Oval Office with the
with the Democrats President Trump this
morning was headed down to the border
and he was very very upset with
Democrats for not offering him anything
he said that China is more honourable
than Chuck and Nancy and having
tremendous success with China and I find
China frankly in many ways to be far
more honorable than Brian Chuck and
Nancy I really do I think that China is
actually much easier to deal with the
opposition party okay that's ridiculous
and the President of the United States
should not be saying things like that if
Obama had said it about Republicans I
would have said that's it's that's
insane okay China is a communist for
oppressive tyranny the idea that we're
negotiating with China better than Trump
can negotiate with Americans who may not
share his political priorities but at
least are not attempting to impose you
know a restrictive communist regime that
kills dissidents and that that seems
like an overstep by the presidents of
the United States but President Trump
not one who is known for understatement
and deeply a moral statement there by
President Trump he's on more solid
ground when he says the Democrats don't
obviously give a care they give a damn
about illegal immigration here he is not
and this is the point he actually should
be hammering no reason why we can't come
to a deal but you have another side that
doesn't care about border security the
Democrats which I've been saying all
along they don't give a damn about crime
they don't care about crime they don't
care about gang members coming in and
snapping people and cutting people up
they don't care about crime and if
they're not gonna care about crime that
I agree they shouldn't do anything at
the border but I care about crime it is
you know not a horrible argument the
Democrats don't care about crime
especially when they make some of the
worst arguments in the world Nancy
Pelosi apparently in this meeting with
President Trump Trump was talking about
a wall and Nancy Pelosi kept saying to
him but people will just build tunnels
underneath the wall oh my god you're
right it's much easier to just build
tunnels underneath the wall than to walk
across where there is no wall the long
history of people walking across things
where there's no demonstrates it's a
little easier to walk across things than
to build a tunnel underneath them as the
end crenshaw points out I can't imagine
how this conversation went from close i
i wonder well and Pelosi says well
people will bet just but kinda under the
wall in terms well will fled the toes
and then Pelosi is like well I bring
rafts and Trump be like well we'll sink
their rafts right well they have scuba
gear like that what this is how these
conversations must have gone we are now
living in the stupidest timeline in
which people make the most inane
arguments and when Democrats say that a
wall doesn't make things more difficult
of course a wall makes things more
difficult just by definition
honestly I I only wish that the
conversation had been about using
trebuchet is to throw drugs over the
wall right then they could have said
that the wall was a medieval implement
and trumple his head read that says it
works and then Pelosi would have said
yeah people will bring catapults and
trombe you like and that's why I brought
this dragon right this all this is
dumber it's 5.7 billion dollars the
Democrats reassigned the money we should
be done but we're not gonna be done
because Democrats think that they can
exact some sort of bargain out of trump
and they figured the American people I
think the hest of the media are going to
fall exactly where they want them to
fall which is blaming Trump for the
shutdown
however it's not going completely
according to plan some Democrats are
urging people like Pelosi and Schumer to
just cave and sign over the money
because we are now about to enter an
actual non paid
and for members of the federal
government starting January 11 people
start missing paychecks that great
political minds share was tweeting out
today
you know she was wondering if there is
life after love and also why Nancy
Pelosi and Chuck Schumer would not
actually would not actually just sign
over the money she has the weirdest
capitalization habits on Twitter like
much weirder than president Trump's she
says Trump said Mexico will pay for it
while will pay for itself how about
billions in maintenance every year
Trump alliance' its new self-cleaning
wall fence hedge bamboo curtain iron
curtain chintz curtains and blind stop
lying and stop the bleep shut down now
start snap okay and then she continued
for Trump this is political but real
people are really suffering where was
the bleep crisis one month ago one year
ago where has been for the last two
years
having said that Nancy you are a hero
let him have his blanking money people
will starve lose their homes be unable
to see doors doctors and able to see
doctors so so share I think may actually
represent a certain contingent of the
Democratic base that that is annoyed
that the Democrats continue to play
politics with a lot of Democratic
constituents because the media every
time they focus in on the impact of the
shutdown it's not just hitting trumpets
hitting Democrats as well USA Today has
a long piece today about how the
shutdown is impacting Americans they
talk about the the the fact that there's
kind of businesses that are ancillary to
to government areas are suffering they
talk about the guy Mike Johannes has run
a food stand in downtown Washington for
the past 20 years surviving economic
downturns while selling hotdogs candy
bars and an assortment of other edible
items but the latest government shutdown
could be the death knell for his
business foot traffic is markedly down
at the corner of Penn Ave and 11th
Street where he operates and Johanna
said sales have fallen about 60% during
the closure which has affected nearby
federal offices museums and other
tourist spots and you're getting all
these sorts of stories from the media
day after day this idea that the idea
being of course that there's actual
suffering that happens during a
government shutdown apparently the
federal government loses about a billion
dollars a week during a government
shutdown
thanks to back pay they're gonna have to
pay people and and other failures to
take in revenue and all the rest so
Democrats are gonna feel that pressure
to and this is why it from should stand
tall unfortunately it looks like Prez
Trump is looking more and more at
declaring a national emergency and
that's something that he really should
not do at this point declaring national
emergency as I said yesterday would be
both fruitless it would also be it would
also be just bad constitutional the bad
constitutional politics the executive
branch does not have the capacity to
randomly declare a national emergency
and then seize land along the border in
violation of eminent domain and then
just start building walls because
there's been an intractable long term
problem Democrats refuse to solve Trump
needs to keep the pressure on Democrats
and again the folks on the Left don't
have a good excuse as to why they don't
seem to care very much about this issue
they don't have a good excuse and I hate
Trump is not an actual solution
I hate Trump doesn't help you at all in
this debate which is why Trump should
keep pushing it and pushing and pushing
it I'm gonna get to just how bad
Democrats and folks on the Left are when
it comes to this issue in just one
second because if Trump wanted he could
have a series of commercials like today
that would be devastating to Democrats
on this particular issue get to that in
just one second so let me tell you
something about my shaving habits did
you see earlier in this show that I
actually had a beard did you see that it
was not a figment of your imagination
during one of the clips all I had to do
to get rid of that beard was grab my
Dollar Shave Club products and go to
town and boom clean shaven beautiful
magnificent that's what Dollar Shave
Club can do for you because Dollar Shave
Club delivers everything I need right to
my door and they keep me fully stocked
on what I use so I don't run out I mean
the fact is I used an awful lot of
shaving cream during that 20 second
period I need a new supply well Dollar
Shave Club will provide that to me on a
regularly scheduled basis they've got
you covered head to toe for your hair
your skin your face they have a new
program where they automatically keep
you stocked up on the products you use
you determine what you want when you
want it it shows a bright your door from
once a month to once every six months
that's what I do
whether it is for shaving or whether it
is for using the amber and lavender body
cleanser which is soothing and calming
which I desperately need and right now
they've got a bunch of starter sets you
can try for just five bucks like their
oral care kit after that the restock box
ships regular size products at regular
price so what are you waiting for get
your starter set for just five bucks
right now at dollarshaveclub.com
slash pen that is dollarshaveclub.com
slash pen again in dollarshaveclub.com
slash men for the special deal you can
try the starter set for just five bucks
like their oral care kit again
that out dollarshaveclub.com slash then
okay so president Trump when he says the
Democrats don't care about crime that
they don't care about illegal
immigration he has a leg to stand on and
it's amazing how blind many folks on the
Left were released in the anti-trump
contingents are to this kind of hole in
their resume so I give you an example
Anna Navarro is a Republican right she's
voted Republican in in a bunch of other
elections although she said she was
going to vote for Andrew Gilliam in the
last Florida gubernatorial race because
she disliked Trump so much which is a
pretty insane contention well last night
on CNN Chris Cuomo actual physical block
of wood Chris Cuomo had on a couple of
guests one was Anna Navarro and one was
a Republican who is talking about the
cost of illegal immigration and the
problem of crime that is linked to
illegal immigrants who are not vetted
and Anna Navarro in the middle of this
clip actually takes out a nail file and
begins filing her nails because she
doesn't care about what happens to
people who are victims of illegal
immigrant crime here's the clip to grant
you that okay the point is the illegal
aliens crime rate should be zero it
should be you can do your nails you know
who can't do their nails are people who
have been killed Anna by dangerous known
illegal aliens who've been allowed to
stay in this country because of the
leftist policies that people like you
promote in so-called sanctuary cities
okay so there she is filing her nails as
he talks about heal imminent crime now
I'm old enough to remember when Corey
Lewandowski who is indeed a bag of tools
Corey Lewandowski was also on CNN and I
believe it was Democrats talking about
victims of a particular type of crime or
government shutdown and turning a member
what the context was and Corey
Lewandowski just had womp womp
and everybody mocked him and suggested
that he never be allowed on CNN again
and of ours they're filing her nails
while they talk about victims of illegal
immigrant crime no problem at all and
this just demonstrates that there is a
blind spot when it comes to the
emotional nature of this issue for a lot
of Democrats who believe that there's no
reason to worry about illegal
immigration in any context well a second
I'm going to show you more of the
reaction to president Trump's
negotiation strategy so President Trump
was negotiating with Nancy Pelosi and
Chuck Schumer and the media are very
angry the
Trump didn't stay in the room that he
walked out of the room with Pelosi and
Schumer now quick flashback Barack Obama
did this right Obama actually did this
back in 2011 hernia Jonathan Alan and
Jake Sherman July 13th 2011 in Politico
President Barack Obama abruptly walked
out of a stormy debt limit meeting with
congressional leaders on Wednesday a
dramatic setback to the already shaky
negotiations he shoved back and said
I'll see you tomorrow and walked out
House Majority Leader Eric Cantor told
them that reporters in the Capitol after
the meeting the White House talks blew
up him at a new round of sniping between
Obama and Cantor who are fast becoming
bitter enemies
apparently the presidents told cancer
don't call my bluff and then he said
that no other president would sit
through such negotiations and then he
just walked out
apparently Obama was impassioned but he
just walked out and Democrats claimed
that Cantor was exaggerating starts
exactly the same thing as what just
happened with Trump and Pelosi was there
in this kind of media coverage did Erin
Burnett get on the air and talk about
how a president can't walk out of
negotiations well she did last night on
CNN is it the person at the center of a
negotiation when the outcome is whether
his government reopens KITT just say
bye-bye Trump pass the lead well no
actually he can't say bye-bye that's one
of the tactics of negotiation and any
negotiation there comes a point where
you have to say together said listen I'm
getting up and I'm walking out because
there's nothing more for us to discuss
here now the problem is that Trump's
fallback position is a bad position
Trump's fallback position is that he is
going to declare a national emergency
and that the national emergency is going
to allow him to build a wall on the
border that is not what's going to
happen if he declares a national
emergency and tries to activate the
military a judge will put forward an
injunction in about five minutes flat
the wall will not be built he will sign
the Democratic funding bill into law
everything will be funded no wall will
be built he will yell about the
Democrats he will yell about the
judiciary some contingent to the base
will suggest that Trump has done his
part but Congress blew it and then we
will all move on with our lives while
Trump gets credit with his base it will
be a cynical political move either the
president is committed to this or he's
not committed to this our youth either
he's committed to go all the way on this
issue or he's not committed to go all
the way on this issue I don't think
there's a lot of in-between here with
that said they're trying to find an
in-between now so according to CNN
there's deal-making in the works some of
these deals are not very good now recall
just a few months
the White House had actually offered the
Democrats that they would essentially
give amnesty to over a million illegal
immigrants and dreamers people who are
brought here when they were young that
they were to offer all that amnesty to
illegal immigrants in response to a
border wall and the Democrats walked
away from that deal but now the White
House is coming back and they're saying
well maybe we can make another sort of
deal that'll be along those same lines
here's Mercedes lap from the White House
comms office on CNN last night part of
the exchange that Democrats and in many
Republicans appear to open to would be
money for the wall more money for the
wall in exchange perhaps for a deal on
daca let me ask you one doctor because
Republicans have raised this to Newt
Gingrich among them would the president
be willing to exchange protection for
dreamers for more money for the wall we
have been open for discussion open for
negotiations for the Democrats okay and
the fact is that Trump was open to those
negotiations a while ago right President
president from back in October of 2017
Henson had suggested that he would push
daca even without a wall and then he
said okay well you know we'll do daca
for the wall and then Democrats balked
at it so it's not really a shock that
they're now bringing this up again this
has ticked off some of the real
immigration hardliners like Ann Coulter
who say that the dreamers should never
be given amnesty it would in my opinion
be a mistake to give the dreamers
amnesty without actually having the
physical barrier in place because now
you're creating a new magnet and you're
saying to folks that if you get in if
you cross that border if you lie about
when you got here or if you just cross
the border and then hope for the next
round of these sorts of negotiations
then you will be able to get citizenship
as well the way this really should go is
that Trump if Trump wants to make a
dreamers for wall deal what he really
should do is you should say here's the
deal I build the wall and then when the
Department of Homeland Security declares
that the border is secure then all these
folks get in the back of him line for
citizenship it's always been my
perspective by the way they're treating
illegal immigrants as a full class as a
mistake and what we actually should be
doing is treating illegal immigrants on
a one-to-one basis meaning the same way
that we would legal immigrants if you
seek to immigrate to the United States
as an individual then we are going to
run you through the rigors of having to
pass an immigration test we're going to
have to look at your background we are
going to have to decide whether you are
of net benefit or of net
meant to the United States and then we
decide whether you can come and whether
your family can come and all the rest
why that wouldn't apply to people who
are already here is beyond me
just because you cross the border
illegally ten years ago I don't see why
we shouldn't be able to make the same
assessment as to whether you are of cost
or benefit in fact that assessment
should be a lot easier we've had ten
years to learn whether you're gonna be
on welfare or whether you're going to
have a kid who's in a gang or whether
you are going to assimilate into
American culture in a fulsome way now we
should be analyzing people on an
individual one-to-one level that's
really how we should handle all of this
but the truth is that immigration is
actually susceptible to some pretty
common-sense solutions it's just that
Democrats don't want the common sense
border solutions and Republicans are
hesitant to cave on any of the other
solutions until they have a border
solution a position that I think is
ultimately rational with that said it's
pretty obvious that Lindsey Graham and
some of the border doves in the
Republican caucus are now trying to get
Trump's commitment to a wall to push
them into a more liberal position on
immigration and this is where the danger
comes in for the Trump administration
they basically have three options at
this point option number one stick to
their guns say we're not going to fund
the government unless you give us the
border security funding we need option
number two declare a national emergency
sign the funding wait for a court to
strike it down whine about it and hope
that Republicans aren't too pissed
option number three go back to Democrats
and give away the store in exchange for
the wall an option number three
unfortunately seems to be gaining a fair
amount of steam according to CNN today
after a president Trump stormed out of a
White House meeting with congressional
leaders GOP senators privately gathered
in Senator Lindsey Graham's office on
Wednesday to discuss a way out of the
logjam the longshot idea proposed an
immigration deal that would include 5.7
billion dollars for Trump's border wall
along with several provisions that could
entice Democrats those items include
changes to help those who are a part of
the deferred action for childhood
arrivals program as well as immigrants
from El Salvador and other countries
impacted by the temporary protected
status program along with modifications
to h-2b visas h-1b visas are
high-skilled immigrants h-2b visas are
unskilled immigrants the plan is in its
very early stages its chance of success
are still very uncertain at best
Republicans caution GOP senators pitched
the idea to senior White House adviser
Jared Kushner who said if they came up
with a proposal that got Trump his
border wall money and could pass the
Senate the way
house would be open to more discussions
on the matter he did not say that Trump
would actually endorse such a plan I
think it's unlikely the president Trump
would endorse such a plan given the fact
that he'd get a lot of pressure rightly
so from his right on the issue well I
want to talk about this a little bit
more but first let's talk about your
cell phone bills well the big and big
wireless provider stands for a lot of
things big contracts big bills big fees
AT&T has a new 800 million dollar
administrative fee increase what big
Wireless does not want you to know is
that there is a way to cut your wireless
bill down to just 15 bucks a month
introducing mint mobile the
game-changing company that's taking
everything wrong with big wireless and
made it right you can save like a
thousand bucks a year with MIT mobile
without sacrificing quality of service
because mint mobile makes it really easy
okay like 15 bucks a month use your own
phone along with any mint mobile plan
and keep your old number along with all
your existing contacts and you choose
the amount of data you want
you know the unlimited data you're
really not using it choose between 2 5
or 10 gigabyte 4G LTE plans no more
paying for that unlimited data and if
you are not 100% satisfied Mobile has
you covered with their 7 day money back
guarantee so try it for a few days see
if it works for you if not get your
money back ditch that old wireless bill
start saving right now with mint mobile
to get your new wireless plan for just
15 bucks a month plus free shipping on
your new mobile SIM card go to mint
mobile comm slash man that is mi NT
mobile comm slash man again cut your
wireless bill to 15 bucks a month get
free shipping on your mobile SIM card at
mint mobile comm slash Ben that's mint
mobile comm slash Ben go check it out
right now so the negotiations seem to be
ongoing president Trump heads down to
the border today he does so amidst new
media reports that the steel wall won't
even work so again Democrats media
they're struggling to explain why there
shouldn't be any sort of barrier
particularly because even people who are
members of the Obama administration say
the walls work everyone knows that walls
work for example President Obama's
Florida former Border Patrol chief he
came out earlier yesterday and he said
yeah of course walls work like water why
are we being stupid about this
attended the National press conference
along with the president of the border
troll Council Brandon John and Brandon
got up and he said something that was
very sustained and very true the wall
works I'm here today breaking my silence
to tell American people that the
president is
correct and what he's doing the wall
works 100% and I'm here today to support
his efforts and what he's doing to get
what he needs to improve or security for
this great nation you know I think that
you would be I think you would be
hard-pressed like really hard pressed to
find a Border Patrol agent who thinks
that the wall would not be effective in
any way and when Democrats keep claiming
that it wouldn't be effective in any way
they have no evidence to back all this
in fact whenever they try to suggest
that a wall is unnecessary they end up
shooting themselves in the foot for
example Democratic Representative Juan
Vargas he says there's no border crisis
we don't need a wall San Diego for
example is doing great here he is
talking with Don Lemon again another one
of the best and brightest over at CNN I
live along the border and about that a
little over 10 miles from the border
it's San Diego I mean it's basically
paradise it's one of the safest places
in the country and the notion that we
have a crisis there security crisis is
absolute nonsense
a fence or a giant wall would absolutely
do no good no good at all and and that's
why I don't think it'll ever be built
I think it's fantasy there is a wall in
San Diego there's a border wall over
there it turns out that having a border
wall is actually quite useful and we saw
that when there was video of people from
the last March on the border from that
last caravan who actually tried to cross
the border illegally but it turns out
there were fences to stop them and so
they started throwing rocks at border
police officials and so of course it's
gonna be a very difficult argument to
make now the best argument that can be
made against the wall is that it's not
necessary to build like a 2,000 mile
wall which is true right you actually
need sections of wall in certain areas
but the wall itself is not going to stop
all illegal immigration the real problem
of illegal immigration on a more
deep-seated level is the problem of
employers being able to hire illegal
immigrants and not only that the facts
that the vast majority of people who are
illegal immigrants in the country right
now are people who got in legally and
then overstayed their visas that said
the system is absolutely and obviously
broken and Democrats are claiming that
President Trump is trying to curb the
ability to claim asylum but the problem
is that the vast majority of people
claiming asylum are doing so
fraudulently they're not actually
political refugees from their country
they're just looking for a better job
now I don't blame people who are coming
here for a better life my great-great
grandparents did I don't blame people
we're trying across the border because
they live in a country that's that's
really roughing and economically feeble
and they decide that they want to move
here for a better life however I'm not
gonna pretend that they're not abusing
the laws or that our laws have to allow
everybody and this is one of the
consequences of having a welfare state a
vast welfare state by the way now it's
really fascinating to watch all the
people on the left in the United States
who simultaneously want a vast welfare
state and also open borders the same
people who say that they really admire
the Nordic states failed to recognize
that the reason that the Nordic states
are capable of maintaining their giant
welfare state is because they're
extraordinarily restrictive in terms of
their immigration policies in fact the
open immigration policies in Sweden led
to the election of a center-right
government the same thing happened in
Denmark the Nordic states look at their
their vast bevy of welfare state
policies and it turns out a bunch of
people coming into their country who
then create cultural enclaves and take
advantage of the welfare systems are not
good for those countries and so these
democratic socialists these these social
democracies of the of the Nordic part of
the globe those social democracies are
very restrictive in terms of immigration
which is why until five minutes ago that
was even Bernie Sanders's position but
now the Democrats have decided that they
want to things that are not at all
comprehendible you can't actually have
both of them they are mutually exclusive
massive welfare state open emigration
these are not things that you can have
at the same time for the same reason you
can't have free free giveaway free
samples and no limit right if you owned
a store and it was free samples no limit
what do you think would happen everybody
would rush in and bankrupt you in a day
well that's what happens in the United
States how it used to be and this is why
I'm a libertarian on immigration as a
general rule it used to be that anybody
who wanted to come to the United States
and work hard without any guarantee of
getting ahead was free to do so because
there was no welfare state to make sure
that they were going to be paid a
minimum amount what that actually meant
is that the type of immigrant coming to
the United States was a little bit
different now there's still plenty of
great immigrants coming to the United
States who just want to get ahead they
just want to work they don't actually
want to be on our welfare programs but
by polling data the number of immigrants
today who are coming to the United
States and believe that the government
should do more for them is probably a
lot higher than it was a hundred years
ago when people came to
United States having left all their
property back in the old country and
saying I've come here for the adventure
I've come here for the opportunity
America used to be the land of
opportunity but that opportunity was an
opportunity you made yourself this is
one of my chief areas of angst and
disagreement with folks like Tucker
Carlson
the entire promise of America is the
promise of adventure the entire promise
of America always was the idea for
immigrants and non emigrants alike that
you were born into a system where the
opportunity was available to you but it
was up to you to grab it with both hands
and you could find the community to
support you you can find a society of
people who were willing to stretch out
their hands and give you opportunity but
you were not coming here with the
guarantee that there was going to be
some safety net catching you that makes
walking the tightrope dangerous and that
means that you end up with a group of
people coming here or risk seeking a
group of people who are forced to
assimilate into the dominant cultural
mores mores in order for them to succeed
in society assimilation is forced by
free markets assimilation is forced by
capitalism your hard work risk seeking
that is that is pushed by capitalism if
you come to the United States and
nothing is handed to you you learn
English that's what happened to my
great-grandparents and then my yeah my
great-grandparents came here like 1907
and they would have they came here
speaking Yiddish with no money and then
they learned English and their kids
learned English my grandmother doesn't
really speak Yiddish because they didn't
speak Yiddish in the home specifically
because America as a land of opportunity
still required you to do certain things
in order to take advantage of those
opportunities now doesn't mean America
has always been perfect it doesn't mean
everybody has been given equal access to
those opportunities the great the grand
and great moral story of America
is those opportunities becoming more and
more open to more and more people on a
moral level right at the same time that
America was freely welcoming immigrants
in the early 20th century Jim Crow was
prevalent in the south there have been
too many times in American history where
people were not welcomed to the
opportunities of America but that was a
problem with the laws preventing access
to the opportunity it was not a problem
with the opportunity itself and I think
that right now this is my general
problem with the Nordic states as well
as both right populism and left populism
in the United States what they what the
only
right and left populism in the United
States and in Europe by the way is
basically not the question of whether
there should be a massive state but
whether there should be restrictions on
immigration and the left says well
you're cruel and nasty because you want
restrictions on immigration and the
right says well you can't practically
have no restrictions on immigration and
welcome tons of people to the United
States with the giant welfare state the
actual solution to all of this is to
have a government that guarantees far
less and that welcomes far more that's
the actual solution that's the warm
hearted solution that sounds cruel it
sounds nasty it is not it is precisely
the opposite the most generous society
is the society that says come here we
welcome you with open arms if you're
willing to work if you're willing to
risk if you're willing to join our
common journey toward a better future if
you're willing to adventure right if
you're willing to take that call if
you're willing to pick up that call and
go become American that's what the
American Dream was all about it wasn't
that the American Dream was you come
here and we hand you a welfare check and
the American Dream wasn't your born in
America and we hand you a welfare check
and then we protect you from foreign
labor that was not the American dream
either the American Dream was you come
here and you will be left to your own
devices to succeed or fall on your own
merit so go out there and earn right
that was the American dream and build
communities capable of instilling the
virtue necessary to make all of that
happen let me talk a little bit more
about that in just a second first you're
gonna have to go over to Daley wire calm
when you go over to Daley wire calm then
you will get the rest of the show live
you'll also get three hours of me a day
okay I'm like breaking my neck here for
you folks I'm putting on beards I mean
what do you want from me yeah we've got
three hours a day of programming when
you do the podcast and then later today
I do another two hours of live radio
which is available in a lot of major
markets but if you actually want to
watch it live you have to be a
subscriber if you want to watch it later
you have to be a subscriber all that
available over at Daley wire.com for $99
here you get all of that plus you get
this at the very greatest and beverage
vessels the leftist here's hot or cold
tumblr behold its glory it is indeed
magnificent in fact during you know
before I had the beard I was like 10
years older I took one sip from this
tumbler and the years fell off of me it
was just unbelievable go check it out
right now $99 a year you get all those
things please subscribe over at iTunes
please subscribe over a YouTube as well
when you do you get the rest of this
show live also you get the Sunday
special we have a lot of great Sunday
specials coming up this week is Heather
McDonald we're always providing a great
content so go check it out
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
so one of the just to continue with it
with the theme of where we ought to be
on immigration an ideal world what we'd
have is a country that was built on
virtue because virtue is the predicate
for freedom you need virtue before you
can have freedom I think that people on
all sides of the aisle have forgotten
that virtue is necessary before freedom
freedom freedom doesn't create virtue ok
freedom does not make you more virtuous
freedom offers you the opportunity to
either act with virtue or to act as a
libertine freedom gives you the
opportunity to make a choice for good or
for ill but in order for freedom to be
maintained you actually need a virtuous
Society so to take an example all the
folks who are big advocates of the
welfare state they say well what happens
if there were no welfare state people
just wouldn't care for each other and
that's why we need the government to
step in that's why we need the
governments who use force to take money
from John and give it to Jim right
that's why we need to do all of that and
the proper answer to that from a
conservative point of view is know if
you have a virtuous population we do
take care of each other on a voluntary
basis and as I said before I'm a member
of north and ox Jewish community there
are people in our community who are
hurting when people are hurting the
rabbi comes to folks like me and says we
have somebody who can't get through a
Shabbat we need some help this family
needs some help and I sign a check on a
voluntary basis and this is common
across the nation four hundred billion
dollars of charity from Americans every
year mostly to other Americans so a lot
of money and Americans are happy to do
it because common virtue based in a
judeo-christian value system was the
basis for the freedom that the
Enlightenment eventually brought about
politically speaking it seems though
that we've cast all of that aside and so
now we have these kind of surface-level
debates about not the necessity of the
welfare state but about whether we ought
to make that welfare state accessible to
everybody outside the left sense is
unkind not to open up that welfare state
to everybody on the outside and the
right says it's unkind to American
citizens to open up that welfare state
to everybody outside the real answer
should be the do welfare state itself is
a problem and I've said for years I've
said for years that immigrants who want
to come here and work hard and not rely
on welfare and integrate into the
greatness of American philosophy I'd
rather have millions of those people
than domestically born Americans who
don't believe in any of those values and
believe they're owed some things by dint
of being born inside a certain set of
borders America
was always an idea how do you know is
always an idea because it wasn't always
a territory and America used to be
relegated to the original 13 colonies
and then it was relegated east of the
Mississippi and now it's the entire
continent but people who are coming to
the United States knew that they were in
for something they knew what they were
getting and what they were getting was
something grand something magical
something they wouldn't get anywhere
else the opportunity to do what they
wanted to do on the basis of having a
community that would also take care of
them but not through governmental means
the identification of society with
government is one of the biggest
mistakes that we make and it's one of
the reasons why we are so at each
other's throats over politics all the
time the reason we want to strangle each
other over matters political on a
routine basis is specifically because of
this is because when the social fabric
decays when we no longer worry about
virtue when we no longer think about our
informal duties to one another outside
the role of government we tend to think
the government is in the words of Barack
Obama the only thing we all share it is
not what we have to do if we wish to fix
the country and it would solve so many
of our problems on so many political
issues from single motherhood to illegal
immigration if all we did for the next
forever was focus on building up that
social fabric once again if all we did
was focus on our communities and our own
virtues and stop worrying so much about
what government policy should look like
and instead of trying to place all of
our hopes in the dunderheaded
politicians who don't know their ass
from a hole in the ground if instead we
focused on building up communities of
virtue and valor of decency and strength
so many of these problems would would
just disappear like magic and we could
go back to a bargain where you woke up
in the morning feeling like it was an
adventure and the inventor was not how
to twist the system to your own benefit
if the only argument we're having about
government is how to twist the
governmental system to our own benefit
then we're no longer arguing about the
role of government we're arguing about
whether virtue ought to exist at all or
not and I think that that that larger
question has gone entirely by the
wayside I'm not doubting the motives of
people who are sympathetic to illegal
immigrants I'm sympathetic to illegal
immigrants - and I'm not doubting the
motives of people who say that we ought
to have more protections against illegal
immigration because I agree with them I
am suggesting that the real solution in
the end is not going to be had even with
a border wall or with straight
immigration enforcement the real
solution is going to be had when we
decide as a society it's time to return
to that original founding bargain
freedom of Labor freedom of movement
freedom to alienate that labor and
freedom within the context of a virtuous
society where we all feel that we are
brothers in arms and not enemies seeking
to steal things from one another okay
speaking of this controversy has now
broken out today again over Steve King
of Iowa now I know representative King a
little bit he asked me to speak at an
economic opportunity forum in Congress
like a year ago I'd met him a couple of
other times it's a vyd Horowitz Freedom
Center events always seemed like a
fairly nice guy he'd been caught in all
sorts of sort of controversies
surrounding his comments about race and
I will be honest with you I thought that
Steve King was a dunderhead right man I
thought that Steve King said dumb things
but they weren't necessarily racist
things but then people would attribute
racist motives to the dumb things that
he said so for example back in 2017
he had tweeted something out about gear
builders who is a popular right-wing
Dutch politician he had tweeted out
builders understands that culture and
demographics are destiny we can't
restore our civilization with somebody
as somebody else's babies and I said at
the time there are two ways to read that
tweet the first is obvious as a racist
tweet the idea is that babies from
abroad cannot be civilized to Western
values that we can't actually bring in
babies from other civilizations and then
civilize them and then they can't be
part of the American bargain that would
be actual racism and it would be
incredibly stupid so stupid and evil
right it would be those two things
because America is indeed built on other
people's babies whether those babies are
born abroad or born here in the United
States is built on other people's babies
I mean all of civilization all of
humanity is built on other people's
babies as well as your own babies so
that was one way of reading the tweet
the other way of reading the tweet is
that King was basically saying that
multiculturalism combined with high
levels of immigration from non-western
cultures shapes destiny that basically
if you bring in a bunch of people who
are not willing to assimilate and not
interested in assimilating that
undercuts Western civilization so if
those babies are not actually babies
they're being brought up in a culture
different from that of the United States
and being told that that is decent and
fine and they don't have to assimilate
at all that that undermines your culture
obviously that's true right I mean if
you were to bring in a billion citizens
of China right
now without any assimilation you'd
change America pretty quickly and so
obviously there's truth to that and a
lot of king's statements were sort of
like this where you could interpret them
one of two ways well the problem is that
now he's making statements that are not
interpret about one of two ways
there they are only interpret Balazs
racism so he made a comment apparently
just within the last day or so where he
said this quote white nationalist white
supremacist Western civilization how did
that language become offensive why did I
sit in classes teaching me about the
merits of our history and our
civilization if you identify white
nationalist and white supremacist with
Western civilization that's actually
racist that's doing it wrong that that
is that is the entire problem again if
the question of Western civilization is
a question of us and them not based on
ideology but based on race this does
make you a racist the the greatness of
Western civilization the greatness of
the judeo-christian construct is that it
does offer an open door to anybody who
wants to join in America what makes
America fantastic is the fact that that
idea is applicable to broad swaths of
people from a wide variety of countries
regardless of place of origin and every
single immigrant group that has ever
come to the United States has been hit
with the hammer of they're not willing
to assimilate enough and then after 20
years they assimilate this happened to
the Germans it happens to the Irish it
happens to the Italians it happened to
the Jews it happens to the Asians right
it's happened to legitimately everyone
who's come to the United States and
America's idea was always capable of
integrating people
well when Steve King identifies Western
civilization with white nationalism the
idea you have to be a certain color in
order to be inculcated in Western
civilization that's actual racism at
this point Congress should should should
censure congressman King and this is
just insane this is just insane there is
a primary candidate against congressman
King right now the the cot the
challengers names guy named Randy
Feenstra in Iowa and I plan on donating
to him today because the Republican
Party cannot stand for this sort of
commentary that identifies color with
civilization when the left does it by
the way also right when they when they
do this whole routine this
intersectional routine where you don't
get to speak unless you're of a
particular color or order or we're going
to
you certain points in the debate based
on your place of origin or ethnicity or
sexual orientation ads garbage it is
even more dangerous garbage when you're
talking about white nationalism and
white supremacism which have a long
horrifying disgusting history in the
United States so I'd recommend everybody
go over to Randy Feenstra for Congress
it's Feenstra for congress.com and give
some money to Randy Fein strife you're a
good conservative Republican enough is
enough this cannot this cannot hold I
mean just it's it's pathetic and and
getting Western civilization this wrong
is frankly unjustifiable it's
unjustifiable we we have some really
deep-seated problems here in the United
States and it seems like everybody is
solving them the wrong way I'm not here
to push my book a little bit early but I
think that if you want to look at the
the problems of Western civilization
civilization group and how those
problems can be cured my book the right
side of history which comes out in March
is all about these specific problems we
have so little in common that people are
rushing to tribalism people are rushing
to political partisanship people are
rushing to woke rage in order to solve a
problem that of the problem of the soul
a problem that we no longer see each
other as friends and compatriots in a
common cause we now see each other as
enemies seeking to tear apart the nation
and that means that a lot of our
political debates too should be boiled
down to something beyond what is
political expedient politically
expedient one of the big problems we
have right now for both Democratic
politicians and Republican politicians
is that the most effective mode of
politics is to question your opponents
motives that is the most effective right
so when President Trump goes after
Pelosi and Schumer and says they don't
care about crime that's a very effective
mode of politicking and Pelosi and
Schumer when credence to it when they
look like they don't care about crime
Pelosi and Schumer consequently go the
other way they say Trump doesn't care
about people who are being hurt in a
government shutdown and Trump lends
credence to that when he sort of shrugs
he at it the reality is do I think that
Pelosi and Schumer actually don't care
about crime from illegal immigrants
probably not but I think that it's
convenient for them to pander to their
base instead what we really our
politicians are a bunch of losers in the
sense that what a good politician does
is has the capacity to tell their own
constituents what is important in
what is not they shouldn't be taking
their lead from their constituents in
terms of what is important when they
think the constituents are wrong that's
a recipe for disaster
and unfortunately I think too many of
politicians on both sides are doing
exactly that okay
when time for a couple of things I like
and then a bevy of things that I hate
I'm gonna hateful mood today so things
that I like so this show has its moment
I'm not gonna say that I love this show
overall because I don't but I think that
it is that the first season particularly
is kind of well-written now what's funny
about the show mr. robot which is on USA
Network is that the show started off as
this kind of critique of capitalism and
capitalism is really terrible and then
within a couple of seasons it morphed
into well really really capitalism is
kind of okay but what we need to do is
curb it so it's it's funny to watch as
over the course of the of the seasons
this show went from Bernie Sanders to
Barack Obama that's really what happened
with this show mr. robot the show is
about this social direct he obviously
has a mental in the show as a mental
illness in who is concerned with tearing
down the system of capitalism at its
roots by hacking major corporate
institutions and the the the best
performance and this is not rami malek
who is very rami malek the best
performance in this is Christian Slater
who is really good here's a little bit
of the trailer as a powerful group of
people out there that are secretly
running the world
I'm talking about the guys no one knows
about the guys that are invisible the
top 1% of the top 1% the guys that play
God without permission and now I think
they're following me employee number ER
two eight zero six five two just a
regular cyber security engineer I'm a
vigilante hacker by night I usually do
this kind of thing from my computer but
this time I wanted to do it in person
I started intercepting all the traffic
on their network that's why I know
there's something strange that's when I
decided to hack you okay so the show is
is pretty good I will say that the least
interesting character is the main
character which was always a problem for
shows like this but it is fascinating to
watch as the writers of the show went
from really almost being communists to
saying well what we really need to do is
blend it like in season 3 of the show
not to spoil anything but in season 3 of
the show it turns out that the people
who have been backing this plate to tear
down capitalism are backed by the
Chinese government and the Chinese
government for some odd reason wants to
Trump to be President so it's that kind
of show
that's what's the irritating about it
but what's hilarious about it is the
fact that they're all these people who
really more agree with the Chinese
government than they do with the
American government and yet they want to
pretend that the Chinese government is
backing the Republicans so it's it's
it's kind of a thing I like to tell some
kind of a thing that I hate but it's a
good window into the mind of a lot of
people on the Left who write for
Hollywood okay time for some things that
I hate the wolf scolds are here the woke
scolds have come the woke schools are
here for a green book director so the or
writer so the this this movie green book
just won a Golden Globe and I haven't
seen it yet so I'm not really going to
critique it but the screenwriter whose
name is Nick Vala Wonga has now deleted
his Twitter account because there is a
tweet from November 2015 talking about
President Trump President Trump had
talked about people cheering during 9/11
the tweet said Donald Trump is 100%
correct Muslims in New Jersey cheering
when towers went down I saw it as you
did possibly a local CBS News and he was
ripped up and down for all of this so
now all of these left-wing journalists
have decided it's necessary to go
through all of his old tweets and
sure make sure that he agrees with all
of their points on everything he then
heads delete his Twitter account because
we're not allowed to say things anymore
now maybe maybe so let's say that he's
wrong let's say that what he said is
incorrect because there's not a lot of
evidence that tons of Muslims his Trump
had said we're celebrating on 9/11 the
footage that you saw was from the
Palestinian Authority where Palestinians
were cheering in the streets and handing
out candy whatever it is this new
practice where we wait till someone has
a moment of success and then we go back
in their history dig something up and
try to destroy them with it is really
quite disgusting it's really gross you
say something new well then you're fair
game but this notion that we're gonna go
back 15 years find something that you
said like Kevin Hart and then try and
wreck you over it it's going to make an
unlivable world because there's no such
thing as forgiveness there's like if L
Wonka came out and said I was wrong to
say that I never should have said it
that wouldn't make his critics more
quiet who'd make them more loud then
they would suggest well what sort of
penance does he have to do does he have
to give money to care like this this
would be the routine that they push now
it is amazing that bigotry in certain
circumstances according to the left is
okay so they'll call Vallelunga a bigot
for that tweet but there will be actual
sitting Democratic senators who will be
religious bigots altogether tulsi
gabbard representative from hawaii who
is pretty far left particularly on on
foreign policy i mean like she is bashar
assad's favorite representative she went
in visited Syria a while back but she's
not wrong about this she called out US
Senator mazie Hirono who is the senator
from Hawaii because her Ono questioned a
judicial nominee and asked specifically
about this judicial nominees membership
in the Knights of Columbus and then some
Columbus is just a Catholic group that
has lunches basically but if you're a
member of a Catholic group this means
that you must be destroyed now according
to a lot of Democrats or we saw Bernie
Sanders do this with another Christian
pretty recently with regard to a
nomination for the Office of Management
and Budget
so Hirono question Brian Buescher and
apparently during that line of
questioning senator Hirono asked
specifically whether the guy could be
fair because he was Catholic because he
was because he was taking part in the
Knights of Columbus
dr. keone Dudley a member of the Knights
of Columbus said that although they
participate in things like the March for
Life
there are Knights
all different kinds of personal views in
there are Knights in elected office by
the way JFK was a member of the Knights
of Columbus Vice President Biden is a
Catholic there there are a lot of
different members of the Knights of
Columbus who are not on the right but
this new sort of religious test that's
being trotted out by Democrats is pretty
astonishing then demonstrates once again
that bigotry is not restricted to any
one political side and so that's that's
pretty gross stuff okay so we will be
back here tomorrow with all of the
latest we'll bring you all the updates
from President Trump's visit to the
border wall also we'll be here a little
bit later today so if you subscribe for
$9.99 a month you don't have that wait
till tomorrow get the updates later
today we'll bring you all the drama all
the action and all the fascination this
is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wha
era the Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
Ford publishing production copyright
Ford publishing 2018